В ефірі новини дня «heute 19 Uhr» з Яною Парайґіс.
Добрий вечір.
Німеччина знову здобуває золото на Чемпіонаті світу
з веслувального слалому в Аугсбурзі.
Так, справжня гонка мрії на байдарках для олімпійської чемпіонки
Рікарди Функ.
А зараз інші актуальні новини дня:
Чіткі меседжі у Туреччині - схвальні реакції опозиції в країні
для міністерки закордонних справ Німеччини Бербок
за її відкриту критику турецького уряду.
Пожежі, посухи та короїди -
катастрофічний рік для багатьох німецьких лісів.
Провал ФК «Леверкузен»:
команда Бундесліги вилітає в першому раунді Кубка Німеччини
проти команди третього дивізіону «Ельверсберг».
Після розмови на підвищених тонах
міністерки закордонних справ Німеччини Бербок
зі своїм колегою Чавушоглу
на початку її візиту до Туреччини
Бербок зустрілася також з кількома опозиційними партіями.
Вони позитивно відреагували на чіткі слова Бербок
до уряду Туреччини
з питань зовнішньої політики
та ситуації з дотриманням прав людини в країні.
Репортаж Патриції Відемаєр.
Частина обов'язкової програми кожного
офіційного візиту до Анкари:
покладання церемоніального вінка до мавзолею Кемаля Ататюрка,
засновника Турецької Республіки.
Міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини
теж дотримується цієї традиції.
Але розмови під час візиту не зовсім приязні.
Надто підвищений і жорсткий тон панував минулого вечора
під час розмов і спільної пресконференції
Бербок з її турецьким колегою.
Бербок піддалася гострій критиці, оскільки під час візиту до Афін
вона засудила претензії Туреччини на острови Греції.
Пані Меркель завжди була щирою посередницею,
політика Німеччини була збалансованою.
Я не вимагаю від Вас прийняти нашу точку зору,
але ми очікуємо, що Німеччина залишатиметься
неупередженою та справедливою.
Це новий, цілком інший стиль.
Бербок проводить довготривалі бесіди
з представниками опозиції та неурядовими організаціями,
які в свою чергу покладають великі сподівання:
Німеччина - важлива країна, тому ми очікуємо
активних дій для підтримки і просування демократії,
принципів правової держави та прав людини.
Німецько-турецькі відносини - це більше,
аніж просто співпраця в окремих сферах.
Це передусім відносини,
засновані на спільності.
Обмін досвідом громадянських суспільств -
це основний елемент нашої співпраці.
Більше жодних розмов про турецький уряд.
Вчорашній гучний обмін думками
був, мабуть, занадто запеклим.
Опозиція заявляє, що врешті заговорили чіткими меседжами,
прямо, «без прикрас»,
як це власне робить і сам міністр закордонних справ Туреччини.
Анналена Бербок знає, що їй потрібна Туреччина
як партнер з багатьох питань.
Однак вона відкрито заперечує і критикує певні позиції,
чого вже досить давно не робив жоден
міністр закордонних справ Німеччини.
Три дні, дві країни -
нелегка подорож для Міністерки закордонних справ Німеччини.
Хто несе відповідальність за ракетний удар
по колонії на Сході України у Донецькій області?
Росія і Україна продовжують звинувачувати одна одну.
Міністерство оборони Росії опублікувало
сьогодні списки імен
50 вбитих та 73 поранених військовополонених.
Президент України Зеленський стверджує,
що це «свідомий російський воєнний злочин».
Червоний Хрест вимагає доступу
до зруйнованої колонії.
Детальніше - Аксель Конрад.
Вони звинувачують Росію
і виходять на мітинги за своїх героїв.
У багатьох з цих людей були родичі у колонії в Оленівці,
досі невідомо, чи їхні рідні ще живі.
Але їм зрозуміло, хто винен у смерті
понад 50 українських полонених.
На місці трагедії, в Оленівці, в окупованому Донецьку,
сепаратисти просувають іншу версію:
вони показують залишки техніки, яка нібито американського зразка.
Після того, як військовополонені
розповіли про воєнні злочини українських військових,
вчинені за наказом Києва,
українська влада вирішила здійснити обстріл колонії
з американських реактивних систем залпового вогню.
Українська розвідка звинувачує Росію,
що будівля була підірвана російськими силами.
За словами української розвідки, так росіяни хотіли приховати злочини,
вчинені над українськими полоненими.
«Це був свідомий російський воєнний злочин,
свідоме масове вбивство українських військовополонених».
Звинувачення обох сторін, між якими іде війна,
досі не перевірені незалежною стороною.
Тим часом бойові дії тривають у багатьох частинах України.
Горить поле пшениці біля Харкова, на півночі країни.
Очевидно, що це сталося не випадково чи через природні явища,
а після прицільного вогню.
«Зараз жнива, і вони свідомо обстрілюють нас
і нашу техніку».
200 км на південь, у місті Запоріжжя,
водій комбайну їздить тільки у бронежилеті.
Каска теж під рукою.
Ракетний удар тут може поцілити будь-коли.
Адже це було б не вперше.
Ми повинні підтримувати країну в нормальному режимі.
Ми повинні забезпечити зерно: сіяти і жати.
Щоправда, вперше в нашому житті за таких умов.
Одна за одною вантажівки заїжджають і відвантажують зерно.
Проте досі не відправлено урожай
ще за минулий рік.
Напоготові у портах Одеси щонайменше 16
вантажних суден, повністю завантажених,
готових до відправлення, але так і не відомо, коли це буде.
Анна Брюль з нами на зв'язку з Одеси.
Анно, ще від вчора люди чекають
на дозвіл, щоб кораблі відплили.
Яка ситуація зараз?
За останні кілька днів ми багато їздимо по країні.
Ми побачили ці гігантські жнива на полях,
і усі кажуть, що потрібно якомога швидше
відправити кораблі з зерном.
Ми зустріли фермера, у якого на подвір'ї
15 тис тонн нового врожаю пшениці.
Він каже, що завжди привозив свій урожай
безпосередньо до порту, який знаходиться за 2 км від нього.
Він і багато інших вважають, що Росія
відповідальна за затримку з відправленням зерна.
Ситуація в Одесі дуже напружена, росіяни завдавали
ракетних ударів як по порту, так і власне по місту.
У місті багато блокпостів, жорсткий контроль,
особливо на береговій лінії.
Дуже велике занепокоєннявикликає те, що
Росія може використати
зернову угоду з метою нових військових дій.
Протягом двох днів у вересні 1942 року
націонал-соціалісти Німеччини та їхні помічники
розстріляли понад 33 тис євреїв
у Бабиному Яру,
на території сучасної столиці України - Києва.
Масові розстріли стали найбільшим масовим вбивством
під час Другої світової війни на території Європи.
Це місце німці зробили місцем страти
протягом всього часу окупації.
Тисячі сінті та ромів також були жорстоко убиті.
Уповноважений уряду Німеччини з протидії ромофобії
Мехмет Даймагюлер сьогодні теж прийшов до меморіалу,
щоб покласти квіти і вшанувати загиблих.
Новини з Іраку.
Прихильники впливового
шиїтськогосвященнослужителя Муктади аль-Садра
увірвалися до іракського парламенту
вже вдруге за цей тиждень.
У боротьбі за владу рух «Аль-Садр» хоче перешкодити
політичним опонентам сформувати уряд.
Демонстранти розбили барикади перед «зеленою зоною»,
що суворо охороняється.
Тут знаходяться багато державних споруд
та іноземні посольства.
Щонайменше 60 осіб були поранені.
Після шестиденної подорожі до Канади
уперше з'явилася інформація
про відставку Папи через проблеми зі здоров'ям.
Франциск сказав, дослівно,
«немає проблеми змінити Папу».
На зворотному шляху Папа поділився з журналістами,
що поки не думає про те, щоб покинути Святий Престол.
Смерть від 4 до 6 тис дітей та підлітків
корінного населення Канади Папа уперше
назвав «геноцидом».
До 1996 року 150 тис хлопчиків і дівчаток
були відлучені від своїх сімей і позбавленісвоєї культури
в школах католицької церкви.
Багато з них зазнали фізичного та сексуального насильства.
Стати солдатом чи солдаткою за 20 днів навчання?
Не вдасться.
Але можна стати резервістом.
Те, що спочатку звучить незвично,
згодом здобуває все більшого резонансу.
Асоціація резервістів вбачає підвищений інтерес
людей, які хочуть пройти навчання.
Після навчання вони хочуть служити в роті і бути залученими,
наприклад, у разі катастрофи
або як підкріплення в службі безпеки військових об'єктів.
Детальніше - Крістель Гаас.
Навчальна тривога!
Це не зовсім звичні військові навчання.
Ті, хто зайняв свої позиції, - цивільні,
яким вже давно виповнилося 18 років.
Тепер вони хочуть стати резервістами.
Наприклад, Сабріна і Массімо.
Вона - комерційний працівник, він - інженер-технолог.
Їхнє завдання:
розбити табір на нічліг та зробити камуфляж.
Ми хотіли прожити один день з життя військових,
дізнатися, як він проходить.
У випадку катастрофи - ми зможемо допомогти.
Потрібно знати, що ми маємо робити,
якщо мова йтиме і про захист країни.
Бундесверу потрібно більше резервістів для забезпечення
захисту країни після скасування військової повинності.
Протягом чотирьох років вже проходить тренування
для тих, хто не служив.
Двічі по десять днів, включаючи вогневі
тренування з бойовими патронами в комплекті.
Ми тут не у джунглях.
Ми тут у Бундесвері,
тому це відповідна підготовка.
З моменту вторгнення Росії в Україну
Бундесвер є важливою і актуальною темою
у суспільстві та політиці.
Поки що 590 цивільних пройшли навчання ﻿по всій країні.
У наступному році кількість осіб збільшиться на 500.
Інтересу не бракує, - стверджують у Бундесвері.
Приготуватися до приймання їжі, кроком руш!
Як цивільні, так і резервісти мають спільну мету:
бути корисними для своєї країни.
Водночас вони сподіваються,
що братися за зброю їм не доведеться.
Пожежу в районі Ельба-Ельстер у землі Бранденбург,
за офіційною інформацією, вдалося взяти під контроль.
У національному парку Саксонська Швейцарія, навпаки,
триває боротьба з руйнівною лісовою пожежою.
На місці працюють 350 пожежників,
задіяно 13 гелікоптерів.
З обох боків німецько-чеського кордону
знову і знову спалахують нові пожежі.
Пожежа в Ельбських пісковикових горах
спалахнула на минулих вихідних на чеському кордоні.
Лісові пожежі на Сході свідчать
про недостатні опади.
Майже в усіх регіонах Німеччини показники були
значно нижчими за норму.
В окремих районах йдеться про справжню посуху,
зокрема, і в глибоких шарах ґрунту.
Дерева особливо чутливі до такої посухи,
спека та відсутність вологи робить їх більш вразливими
до таких шкідників, як короїд.
Це ідеальні умови для цього шкідника.
Флоріан Корчик побував у лісах Тюрінгії
та побачив шкоду, завдану цими комахами, на власні очі.
Ще менше місяця тому
на цьому місці був густий хвойний ліс.
А потім в деревині завівся короїд.
Дерево гине внаслідок повної руйнації твірної тканини -
камбію, що знаходиться між корою і заболонню,
та, відповідно, недостатнього надходження вологи.
Лісникам лишається вирубувати
інфіковані шкідником ялини
та якомога швидше вивозити їх з лісу,
адже короїди блискавично розмножуються.
Один короїд
може мати 150 000 нащадків.
Таким чином популяція стає настільки численною,
що в сусідніх дерев практично немає шансу на порятунок,
короїд нищить усе навкруги.
Місцеві дерева стають легкою здобиччю,
адже вони надзвичайно ослаблені.
Співробітниця вимірювальної станції
Інес Чмара демонструє,
що до коріння практично не надходить волога.
У цій пляшці мають збиратися ґрунтові води,
якщо вони взагалі є.
Але, як бачите, вона порожня.
Це означає, що між верхнім шаром ґрунту та землею
на глибині 1 метру практично відсутня волога,
необхідна для живлення рослин.
Цього літа в Тюрингії
зафіксовано лише 20-30%
необхідної кількості опадів,
менше, ніж у всіх інших федеральних землях.
Навіть якщо зараз розпочнуться грозові зливи,
це не змінить ситуацію.
Набагато ефективнішими виявилися б
тривалі дрібні дощі.
Проте наразі синоптики їх не прогнозують.
Єдине, що можуть зробити лісники в ситуації, що склалася, -
намагатися мінімізувати шкоду,
ізолюючи уражені дерева від здорових,
та продовжувати боротися з небезпечним
шкідником, який наразі відверто перемагає.
Підйом на канатній дорозі над Рюдесгай﻿мом
до Нідервальдського пам'ятника
з вражаючим видом на Рейн
учора перетворився на справжнє жахіття для 41 людини.
Через технічну несправність
канатна дорога зупинилася.
Рятувальники визволяли пасажирів із підйомників
на висоті до 14 метрів
за допомогою пересувних драбин та мотузок.
Приблизно через три години роботи рятувальників
усі пасажири успішно спустилися на землю.
У суботу по всій території Німеччини
розпочалися літні канікули.
Зокрема, це стало відчутно і на дорогах.
Так, на автобані А1 біля Бремена
утворилися довжелезні затори.
За даними Загальнонімецького автомобільного клубу ADAC,
до завтрашнього вечора
очікуються одні з найбільших заторів сезону.
У Франції ситуація ще гірша.
Дорогою до моря по всій країні
зафіксовано затори довжиною у 800 км.
Щороку на день народження співачки Кейт Буш
відбувається дивовижне дійство.
У парках по всьому світу
збираються тисячі шанувальників у червоному одязі,
щоб відтворити легендарний відеокліп співачки до
культового хіта «Wuthering Heights».
Традиція живе, незважаючи на те, що
пісня вийшла в далекому 1978 році.
Серіал «Stranger Things» сприяв новій хвилі
цікавості до творчості британської співачки.
Себастіан Горські приєднався до
людей в червоному у Берліні.
Сьогодні в берлінському парку Герлітцер
відбувалося щось справді незвичне.
Це своєрідний триб'ют Кейт Буш.
Близько 300 танцівників-ентузіастів
вирішили відтворити кліп 1978 року
на пісню «Wuthering Heights».
Експресивний танець у поєднанні з загадковим текстом
настільки вразили шанувальників співачки,
що навіть зараз, через стільки років, люди виходять на вулиці
в понад 40 містах світу, щоб відсвяткувати чергову річницю хіта.
Приємно бачити, як обличчя людей сяють від щастя.
Стать та вік не важливі, ми просто розчиняємося в ритмі
улюбленої пісні, танцюємо та даруємо один одному позитив.
Ось і все.
Зараз творчість Кейт Буш переживає справжній ренесанс,
хіти 80-х років повертаються у світові чарти.
Породила цю хвилю популярності, проте, інша пісня -
«Running Up That Hill», що стала саундтреком до
серіалу Netflix «Stranger Things».
Саме завдяки серіалу пісня змогла повернутися у
світові чарти через 37 років після релізу
та неабияк зацікавити юну аудиторію.
Я завжди почуваюся так безтурботно,
коли чую цю пісню.
Є в ній щось магічне,
справді хороша пісня.
До того ж «Running Up That Hill» вдало вписалася
в сюжет серіалу,
тому такий ажіотаж, на мою думку, виправданий.
Такий ажіотаж або, як каже молодь, хайп
навколо Кейт Буш може здатися дивним,
проте це неважливо, оскільки, як бачимо,
її пісні справді роблять людей трішки щасливішими.
Що ще робить людей щасливими, то це футбол,
чи не так, Норберте?
Як відомо, результат Кубку Німеччини завжди непередбачуваний.
Саме так, наприклад, сьогодні зі змагань за Кубок
вибули одні з головних фаворитів сезону.
Клуб другої ліги «Регенсбург» переміг
«Кельн» із рахунком 4-3.
А команда третьої Бундесліги «Ельверсберг»
цілком справедливо обійшла «Баєр 04 Леверкузен»
у надзвичайно драматичному матчі з рахунком 4:3.
Увесь стадіон спостерігав за останньою атакою
«Леверкузена» затамувавши подих,
і ось м'яч опиняється прямісінько в руках воротаря.
Вже на другій хвилині відкривається рахунок матчу.
Відповідь не забарилася - через 3 хвилини
гол забиває нападник «Баєра» Гложек.
Однак після рахунку 2:1, а згодом і 2:2,
ініціатива остаточно переходить до «Ельверсберга».
На 74-ій хвилині Кевін Конрад забиває четвертий гол
і рахунок стає 4:2 на користь «Ельверсберга».
«Леверкузен» відповів запізно.
Ось так гравці третьої ліги вибили головного
фаворита з Кубку Німеччини.
На Кубку НФФ справді можливо все.
А ось і попередні результати першого етапу Кубку НФФ.
«Ельверсберг» перемагає «Баєр 04 Леверкузен»
із рахунком 4:3.
«Регенсбург» переміг «Кельн» із аналогічним рахунком.
«Вікторія 1889 Берлін» програє «Бохуму»
з рахунком 0:3.
«Штрелен» мінімально поступається «Санкт-Паулі»
з рахунком 3:4.
«Іллертіссен» поступається «Гайденгайму»
з результатом 0:2.
«Айнхайт Вернігероде» програє «Падерборну 07»
з розгромним результатом - 0:10.
«Байройт»поступається «Гамбургу»
в додатковому часі з рахунком 1:3.
«Любек» перемагає «Ганзу» з рахунком 1:0.
Учора «Мюнхен 1860» поступився «Боруссії Дортмунд»
з рахунком 0:3.
«Динамо Дрезден» мінімально програє «Штутгарту»
з рахунком 0:1.
Розгромна поразка «ТСГ Нойштреліц» у матчі з
«Карлсруе» - 0:8.
І нарешті «Каан-Марінборн» поступається «Нюрнбергу»
з рахунком 0:2.
Детальніше про Кубок Німеччини з футболу згодом,
о 23:00 в новому випуску «sportstudio».
Короткий огляд вже доступний на нашому сайті ZDFheute.de
та в застосунку ZDFheute.
Завтра о 18:00 на стадіоні «Вемблі»
збереться понад 90 тисяч глядачів.
Рекордну кількість відвідувачів збере фінальна гра
Чемпіонату Європи з жіночого футболу - Англія зіграє проти Німеччини.
Німецька збірна
мотивована та впевнена у своїй перемозі.
Фінальний матч проти господарів на
легендарному «Вемблі».
Саме так позиціонувала майбутню гру на
заключній прес-конференції головна тренерка
жіночої збірної Німеччини з футболу
Мартіна Фосс-Текленбург.
Не знаю, що чекає на нашу збірну в майбутньому,
не беруся аналізувати минуле,
але я точно знаю, що це досягнення
стане одним із найвизначніших в історії збірної.
Фінальна гра обіцяє бути грандіозною.
Клара Буль не зможе взяти участь у грі на виїзді
через захворювання на коронавірус.
Однак капітан команди Александра Попп
зараз у своїй найкращій формі -
шість голів у п'яти іграх -
сподіваємося, що Александра на цьому не зупиниться.
Німецькі футболістки мають всі шанси
завоювати дев'ятий чемпіонський титул.
Олімпійська чемпіонка Рікарда Функ здобула золото
на Чемпіонаті світу з веслування на байдарках і каное
в Аугсбурзі,  перемігши в
одиночному запливі на байдарках.
30-річна чемпіонка
веслувала особливо завзято в останній третині запливу,
забезпечивши собі чемпіонський титул
та випередивши австралійку Джесіку Фокс.
Успіх Рікарди в зимових видах спорту
майже повторила Елена Лілік,
здобувши бронзу.
Золота медаль Рікарди Функ стала другою для
Німеччини на цьогорічному Чемпіонаті світу.
Дякуємо, Норберте.
Катя Горнеффер обіцяє, що завтра в країні здебільшого
переважатиме тиха літня погода.
А зараз ми дізнаємося, в яких регіонах варто очікувати
на зливи та грози.
Дивіться «heute journal» о 22:45 з Мітрієм Сіріним.
На все добре.
Добрий вечір. За нашими підрахунками, вчора на
квадратний метр припало лише кілька літрів опадів.
Проте були й такі регіони, де опади
налічують більше 50 літрів на квадратний метр.
Сьогодні вночі останні зливи прокотяться сходом
і залишать Німеччину.
Стовпчик термометра опуститься до 17°C на заході
та до 10°C у Верхньо-Пфальцькому лісі.
Завтра максимальні температури коливатимуться
між 21°C на Північно-Фризьких островах
та 32°C на Верхньому Рейні.
Здебільшого неділя буде надзвичайно приємною.
Сонце чергуватиметься із затінком,
лише на північному заході пройдуть
сильні грозові зливи.
Згодом погода ставатиме дедалі мінливішою.
Ми відчуємо це вже на початку наступного тижня.
У середині тижня, однак,
температура зросте до 35°C.
Але, як і останні кілька тижнів,
така висока температура
протримається лише день або два.
Повернімося на хвильку назад до липня.
Середня температура в Німеччині становила
19,2°C, це на 0,9°C тепліше,
ніж у багаторічному метеорологічному звіті
1991-2020 років,
на 60% посушливіше,
та на 17% сонячніше.
На все добре.